One of the things the operating
system does is protect
resources that need to be protected.
How does that work?
Well, the way it works is
because we give control of
the resources to the operating system.
We say you can't directly, untrusted
applications can't directly access it.
So, operating system has control and
it's actually going to control access to
these resources, and we know it can do
that because of the complete
mediation requirement that we have.
So, anybody who wants access to such
a resource actually has to come through
the operating system and when they
come through the operating system,
the operating system is going to be
able to say yeah this is okay or I'm not
going to allow or grant access or I'm
going to deny this particular request.
So how does the operating system
actually sort of mediate these requests
that we're going to have for
various resources and
that needs to be protected?
First it must establish
who's making the request.
What is the source of the request?
Request always has a source.
The entity that's making the request and
it has a target which is the resource
that is being requested.
So the operating system has to
know who is making the request and
what is being requested.
So the who part is typically answered
by this thing we called authentication.
We're going to talk more
about it in a future lesson.
But authentication essentially
establishes on whose behalf
a certain application or
a process is running.
So that's the user who's
making the request.
Once we know who is making the request
then we have this thing called
authorization or access control.
This is really checking,
looking up if this source of the request
is allowed to access the resource for
which the request is being made, okay.
You may be allowed to
access a certain file or
you may not be able to access a file
because it doesn't belong to you.
So the check that we're going to do
is called the access control check.
So the trusted computer base of
the operating system really does
It doesn't decide who accesses
a given resource or not.
That's called select policy.
You have to decide who you're
going to share your resources with or
what other applications can share
a given file that you have.
So that's the policy.
But the fact that when a request for
the resource comes,
being able to do that access check.
The mechanisms are essentially that part
which intervene between
the source of the request and
the check that we going to do to
determine if the policy that we have in
place is going to tell us whether
the resource can be granted or not.
So the mechanism is essentially
this check that we are performing.
And the goal of address computing
base is to implement and
do that in a structured fashion
the checks or how the mechanisms for
doing these checks that going to allow a
variety of policies to be implemented or
supported in the system.
The protection of the resources
when you talk about it.
Always we have to know where
the request is coming from.
Whether the the requester
is allowed to access it and
that's what the trusted computing base
has to do and it does it by providing
these mechanisms to support variety
of access control policies.